Barry explains to Ben Affleck Bruce
Wayne the disability to go back in time
would allow him to change things
including saving Bruce's parents now
does this mean we might get a flashback
to when it was Jeopardy Morgan I mean
it'd be pretty sick for him to show up
here but remember this Ben act like
Bruce Wayne must know that Barry will
have traveled through time at some point
because of Batman v Superman Barry
visited Bruce threw a portal to tell him
that Lois Lane was the key so this is
why he doesn't completely stop him from
going back in time because he knows
that's just part of fate and part of
Destiny but he's gonna say while you're
running through everything just you know
leave that movie screening as is because
I like paid Batman
foreign